hey guys before I introduce you with a
huge confirmation regarding euron
greyjoy which has actually been
confirmed by an actor that portrays the
same character pillow as bag
let me firstly thank to all worldwide
famous newspaper sites that shared my
theory including Cosmopolitan Daily
Express UK Metro PopSugar Esquire
Digital Sky bus pedestrian and the
others basically in that theory the most
honorable man in the Seven Kingdoms
Eddard Stark is actually alive this
whole time while the man beheaded by Sir
Ilyn Payne on steps of the great Sept of
Baelor wasn't actually net himself but
was rather the faceless men wearing nets
face it's also important to have added
Syrio Forel was of the greatest
importance as in this theory not only
that Syria provided help to Ned but he's
also taken the face that the faceless
man who sacrificed his life for Ned's
was having among a few adder which is
the face of a low-res a criminal jackie
hagar if you're interested in more
details about this theory of minds
supported by a few facts and numerous
skinny hints feel free to check it out
now let's focus on today's topic in the
books iran Greyjoy is one of the most
mysterious and one of the most dangerous
characters beside being a skilled
warrior and manipulator he's also
unpredictable and cruel man known for
his delight in playing vicious mind
games with anyone around him in the fort
novel in the epic fantasy series a Song
of Ice and Fire
yeren brags to the Ironborn to have read
all over the world during his exile
including a trip to the feared ruins of
Valyria urine was mentioned by Tyrion
Lannister in the very first season of
the series in the fourth episode of the
first season
Tyrion tells Theon about his memories of
witnessing the raid on Lannisport caused
by Finn's ankle euron greyjoy however
many book readers are disappointed by
your ins introduction on the show and
are fearing that one of the most
dangerous and evil characters in the
books might not be that much of a
villain on the show despite many
discussions regarding this topic
it seems that urine will be the biggest
villain in the upcoming season while
according to an actor himself urine will
be the greatest villain of the entire
series the official trailers for the
seventh season provided us a few
confirmations regarding your own Greyjoy
it has been confirmed that urine granger
will come to King's Landing after he is
going to successfully defeat ER and send
snakes in the fluid barrel earlier this
season
whereupon he will make a deal with the
new Queen Cersei upon failing to retake
the kingdom of yarn
from urine attempt virtual result with
the deaths of a bar enemy reah hilarious
Anne and her daughter tyene along with
yar are going to get captured that's the
moment in which urine will come to
King's Landing which this shot of the
our own fleet arriving at King's Landing
is confirming as you can see urines
personal sigil on its sails earrings
personal sigil is the standard greater
heraldry of a gold Kraken on black but
it a red eye inscribed onto the head of
the kraken urine will come to King's
Landing and will parade with his
prisoners through its streets parading
all the way to the red cape and will
pledge his army along with his iron
fleet to Cersei but in return sir Sybil
had to marry him while his initial plan
of sailing to slavers Bay to bring the
nears back to Westeros as his wife and
conquered the Seven Kingdoms with their
combined forces failed urine will try to
achieve the same it Cersei as his wife
if you are wondering how am I so sure
that urine will deliver his prisoners to
Cersei well as I already said in one of
my previous videos it's also been
confirmed by HBO as a confirmation that
this major scene really does include
your own Greyjoy offering his forces and
prisoners to serfs in the Great Hall we
have a shot from the recently published
video by the official game of Thrones
youtube channel as you can see an
actress that virtue is hilarious and is
in Chains while sharing a scene in sir C
which is confirming once again that your
answers still make a deal will become
new allies while the official trailer
gave us a few hints regarding your own
stroll in the upcoming season an actor
that portrays the new king of the Iron
Islands confirmed that urine will be the
biggest villain of the upcoming season
in an interview with Empire magazine
below s Beck has revealed and warned
that his character
urine will make the former villains such
as Joffrey and Ramsay look like kids as
Beck said the psychos I've encountered
have so many different sides to them so
it's seen I've done with fewer and I
pick a new thing I'm gonna show this
scene I wanna be charming this scene I'm
gonna be a molester the scene I wanna
kill someone as big worn that after this
season rims is gonna look like a little
kid it's most certainly going to be
interesting to see your own Greyjoy's
role as well as his famous shape the
silence a ship that is screwed entirely
by Muse who stanky personally ripped out
and is said to be infamous from even to
a shy while we all are impatient to see
his famous ship I'm also wondering if
urine has a dragon binder as he has it
in the books a large dragon horn with
Valyrian glyphs
written upon it would represent a big if
not the biggest threat for Daenerys
sincerely that horn should